he once held the Guinness World Record
for most pull-ups with 4030 in 17 hours
he has completed over 60 ultra marathons
triathlons and ultra triathlons he's a
highly successful public speaker and
author he's David Goggins and here is my
take on his top ten rose to success
volume ten enjoy okay let's take it off
with real number one push yourself to
the extreme when I got through with that
first hundred mile race that I did
around that one-mile tract I didn't
prepare for it I was considerably it was
horrible and I'll never forget I found
such peace and beauty and I got I was in
the worst pain of my life and I got done
and my wife pulled the car up on the my
ex wife pulled the car up on this little
lawn and I got in the back of it and I
got the stairs I'm not gonna go through
the whole story but I remember laying in
the tub and she put the shower on me and
I ran a hundred one miles like 19 hours
and I was like peeing dirt out of me
and I'm sitting there and I'm
jackhammering and my body is just the
most broken has ever been even to this
day and this feeling came over me I call
it crazy if you want but very few people
I guarantee ever felt this before to
push themselves so far outside of what
they thought was even possible even for
me I laid in that tub and I didn't want
it to go away
I had drained myself of every bit of
strength energy I had and it was the
best feeling ahead of my life all that
pain it was it was confirmation it was
confirmation that I had gone through a
crucible and I figured out another level
of David Goggins a level that I thought
was humanly impossible for anybody to do
when I was at Mile 70 and pissed all
over myself and had 30 more miles to go
and I was damn near dead and I was able
to go 31 more miles in that process of
the next 31 more miles I
more about myself in that 31 miles than
ever had in my entire life the
conversations the mental blocks the
roadblocks
everything horrible it was just feeding
at me like Lightspeed get the out of
here man like I was able to figure out
different tactics and when I found that
got done with that I lay in that tub and
it was over the feeling of my god man
you just really discovered a whole new
world a whole new part of the brain that
guarantee very few people have rule
number two
tap into suffering so thing about my
state suffering people cringe people
that thought that's the one word
whenever I post about it people cringe
it's not about suffering how people may
look at suffering like you had to dis go
to a place that's just every day of your
life is suffering you have to tap into
suffering every day of your life because
we have so much scarring that we have to
clean up you have to look at suffering
as almost like I look at failure to
succeed you must fail in failure and in
suffering all the answers are in there
all the answers to all the test
questions the test is your life all the
answers are in there you have to live in
suffering and pain and failure all the
time you have to learn I need to visit
it like people hate working out you're
only gonna visit working out maybe an
hour a day 23 other hours of the day
you're not in it hmm but how you become
in shape is you must visit suffering
visits working out one hour a day visit
suffering one hour a day visit your past
failures one hour a day the relationship
with it is the answers are in there they
they are in there within the suffering
go in there and I caught the live
autopsy the live autopsy how you found
out someone died they crack you open
after you're dead how you can live is do
it while you're alive go back in your
brain crack it open while you're alive
don't wait until you're dead
to figure out why you died do it why you
are living go in there go into the
suffering go into the pain of your life
and say why did this suck for me so bad
why am I afraid of all this stuff why am
i shut down the whole world I guarantee
I tell you why you shut down the whole
world it's in these nooks of the
suffering within your brain in the
scarring or all the answers to why you
are on the couch feeling sorry for
yourself they lie within the scars visit
them for at least an hour a day study
them and then you'll find out more about
yourself you will then grow so don't
look at it every day I suffer go into it
an hour a day learn from yourself learn
from life learn from your failures learn
from your insecurities learn from your
self-doubt don't just say I'm afraid to
jump out of an airplane hmm what makes
you afraid of it study it that's why I
studied my mind why became so powerful
in the mind
because I realized I was weak so instead
of running away from the mind I'd over
into him say what is making me weak oh
this makes sense I came from hell I came
from a place that beat me down to
nothing which is why I'm afraid all this
makes sense
so systemically one by one I went back
and met every single person in my mind
every situation I went one-on-one with
them again in my mind it's okay that's
now revisit this and that's how you do
it that's how it works
rule number three study your days I
write down my day and what I do is I go
back and study that day like sometimes I
might I might get sick I might be over
trained I might gain a couple pounds
here I might feel it whatever that and I
it's like my accountability journal of
what I'm doing with my life physical
mental I had an eating Journal all this
and helps me go back to once again study
I'm a lab rat and I studied myself and
I'm like not feeling up I go okay what I
do last week and usually I can find out
where I messed up last week you know how
much I'm travel
and how much I'm doing all this stuff
and and through journaling man you can
really figure out so much about where
you're messin up in life and what you
need to fix about yourself taking
constant inventory costing honest about
that and that's thing about you cannot
put bull in there yeah it's gotta be a
real a real journal about a today I
messed up here today I should have been
a better person here and not just saying
it but actually trying to fix it
tomorrow
reeling before do things your way I sat
back and I had the top five people come
at me top five publishing houses and
it's down to the last two and they're
offering $300,000 I'm a first time you
know first time author and I decided to
go with one of them and three hundred
thousand dollars for a guy at me I'm
Sinbad you know that's pretty good money
so a few days before I was gonna sign
the contract I sat back talk to my
fiance my family and everybody's like
you know hey you know this is good this
is great whatever but I started thinking
about my life I started thinking about
everything that I've gone through my
life everything I had gone through it
had a chance to reflect and that's one
thing I never did in my life was long
enough is have time to reflect I was
always what's next what's next what's
next what's next what's next now that
I'm retired and you have a lot of time
to look back on what you've done where
you started where you're at now and I
said you know what it's not for sale
$300,000 isn't even a fraction of enough
money to sell this so I decided not to
sign it and I saw publish I pissed a lot
of people off and I said I'm not signing
this I'm gonna self-published and that's
kind of how it came to be I took that
time to reflect and I'd rather not make
a dime I wrote this book and that's
honest to God's truth I am fine with the
trophy I have in my mind if you want to
learn how to have more confidence check
out my 254 series they're free the links
to join are in the description below
you will never learn from people if we
always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
what if I can become someone that no one
thinks I can be and just that just be
talking about that I have the hair
growing up on my arms rule number five
constantly evolved I never set out to
write a book when I was in the dungeon
and no one was coming back to help me I
just wanted that reflection in that
accountability mirror that I hate it so
badly to be something that gave me pride
to be something that made me feel it
wasn't but it's not about money it's not
about success isn't about people I'm my
godness david Goggins sign my book No
when I started this journey out years
ago it's about I just want to learn to
read so now I'm at a place now where I
see the possibilities of the human of
human potential
what are we capable of it's a
conversation now the conversation now is
how can I now talk to people in a way
they can understand the message that I
have for so many people for so many
people so that's it that's the new
conversation now that I you are
constantly evolving
you never say you're getting better
you're getting worse not staying the
same hmm so for me after constantly be
getting better I think honestly be
evolving my message so I'm constantly
thinking in the quietness of my mind
rule number six be the best you can be
honestly my biggest fear to this day is
and I say it a lot and I say a lot and
this it's going to heaven and being
judged by God and you know God has I
believe that God has this knows
everything about you from time you're
born when you're gonna be born when
you're gonna die we need a graduate buzz
whatever's going to happen - he knows
all these some people never do what God
knows you're capable of doing cuz you
keep going yet we have choices my
biggest fear in life was to was to get
to heaven and God look at me as I'm
being judged and I was some fat
300-pound guy like I used to be that
still spray for cockroach it was a car
you know that's that's all case what you
want to do I didn't want to do that and
I made a thousand dollars you know a
month I got to heaven and God laid out
this chart in front of me
and they said hey man look at this chart
it had my name on top and all this
amazing I'm like that's not that's not
me man because that's who you were
supposed to be my biggest fear in life
is that one day if I ever get judged by
something someone some some energy force
that go up there and I failed the
mission whatever whatever force up there
thought I supposed to be some badass and
I went up there under achieved you know
I want that force up there that knows
everything to be writing as I'm living
and saying I had no idea he even had
this in a pea so I want to just be the
best I can and a lot people say that I
truly mean that rule number seven be
happy with who you are I realized this
it's not about money it's not about Fame
it's not about being accepted by your
peers and everybody else it's about
figuring out who I am and being happy
with who the I am even though I'm gonna
be judged for all these things be gonna
put a middle finger up to everybody and
say this is David Goggins and to get to
that point it felt great rule number
eight tap into your mind don't do
everything in your life for money
don't do everything yes we needed to
survive there's a great driving passion
behind doing things for the mind in the
soul is a great Drive in that everybody
man you talk with such passion this is a
life this is my life so that's so that's
what I want people to get from all this
stuff man like there's something inside
you the the brain is the most powerful
thing the minds most powerful thing that
we have it's not your phone it's not the
computer it's not anything it's your
mind and if you can tap into that you
can come from the from the daggone roots
of hell and become such a great seed a
powerful see that can grow into some
great daggone garden and people don't
get that it's all up here the power and
the magics up here rule number nine find
your purpose and if you don't believe
that you're here for a reason
your life will seriously hurt
and I start looking at my life and all
this I went through as God put me some
God wherever you believe in put me here
to go through this and now I see all the
hundreds of thousands of lives I'm
changing by the hell I went through
there's a lot of power in that so my
purpose as I started going through this
journey instead of looking like what was
me god man why the man what why also
looking at what's the perfect training
ground you knew exactly what you were
doing you know exactly what the you were
doing obviously you put me in every
situation possible to tell a story that
needs to be told and we'll number 10 the
last one before very such a bonus clip
is don't care what cowards think I get
an email the other day this young man
wants to be a ranger he's afraid to go
to Ranger School not because the heart
of the training is but because he's
afraid if he fails what people are gonna
say by judgement one thing in life it's
the past everything in life anytime you
move from being normal to trying to be
exceptional people aren't gonna like
this those normal people it makes them
feel like she'll judge you and nowadays
it's very easy to be a coward why we've
got instagramers most folks don't tell
you to your face they go online they
post about like cowards
don't let cars get it last day make sure
you do you stay hard now I've got a
special bonus kit from David on how to
fix yourself that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to take an
action here we go
question number one which cowards do you
need to stop paying attention to number
two what is your purpose and number
three how can you be happy with who you
are people are trying to evolve let them
evolve yes let them evolve don't bring
him back into the don't bring them back
where they came from
yes don't don't bring it someone wants
to get better don't bring them back to
where you knew them when they were a
piece of [ __ ] let them fly
and if you feel like hell because they
went away and they escaped the hell that
you all once lived in fix yourself fix
yourself don't hold them accountable cuz
they got away
don't don't constantly remind them that
they were once here fix yourself because
a lot of people feel like crap once
people start to lead their little nests
like like if you're an alcoholic and
this guy said I'm gonna stop drinking
you want to bring them right back in No
look at yourself in the mirror and say
while this guy is doing better take that
feeling of feeling like and do something
about it change your own life
if you want more David Goggins check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there because everybody
else is most people are weak the whole
thing about comfort zones is if you live
in one for too long that becomes your
norm